faire des progrès nous devons arrêter de traiter
nos adversaires
comme des ennemis nous ne sommes pas des ennemis
je nous faisons campagne en tant que démocrate
mais je gouvernerai comme un président américain
joe biden a dit désirer un message
un massage
le virus n'aura aucune chance contre
nous aucune nation n'est  plus préparés nous
apprenons à vivre avec ça les
gens apprennent à mourir avec
ça et puis je vois le désinfectant
mais le fait tomber
en une minute
masque à la langue ne dis pas capacité
ne dis pas complet
ce que je vais  ce qu'il faut faire c'est passer obamacare
avec une option publique
devenir biden care donc c'est
qu'il faut passer vers le
payement je demande à tout le monde de rester calme
politique congrès
élection présidentielle progresse
morial